For all the blood-pumping brawls, sentimental
scenes, and general doom and gloom seen on
screen in Avengers: Infinity War, there was
just as much laughter, banter, and goofs that
played out behind the scenes.
And thanks to the Blu-ray release of Infinity
War, which features a two minute-long gag
reel, viewers at home can witness the best
of those bloopers in one handy spot.
Something wrong with Wong
After Bruce Banner crash-lands at the New
York Sanctum following his cosmic face-off
with Thanos, he meets up with Iron Man, Wong,
and Doctor Strange.
Wong and Doctor Strange give a crash course
on the Infinity Stones, Bruce explains just
how wicked Thanos is, and Iron Man goes to
call Captain America for help, hoping to reconcile
after their falling out in Captain America:
Civil War.
But when Iron Man notices that the wind has
picked up, the four men slowly turn to face
the Sanctum's streetside door and realize
that Thanos' lieutenants have already touched
down on Earth.
Pretty dramatic stuff, right?
Well, during filming, actor Benedict Wong
couldn't really keep it that way.
[Dramatic music]
Bumbling Benedict and Mush-Mouth Mark
They may be two of the smartest characters
in the entire Marvel Cinematic Universe, but
for a few minutes during filming Avengers:
Infinity War, Doctor Strange and Bruce Banner
definitely acted like a couple of doofuses.
When Bruce and Doctor Strange emerge from
a portal and greet Iron Man and Pepper Potts
in the park, actors Benedict Cumberbatch and
Mark Ruffalo seem to forget how to, like,
talk and stuff.
"I'm Doctor, ugh, I'm Doctor I can't walk."
[Incoherent stammering]
Falcon gets funny
Anthony Mackie's Falcon wasn't as major a
player in Avengers: Infinity War as some of
the other superheroes.
But a lack of narrative influence doesn't
equate to a lack of quality bloopers.
During the battle in Wakanda, Falcon soars
through the sky to take down the Black Order
and the Outriders.
Between takes, Mackie made sure to paint a
great mental picture for everyone of what
his scene would look like when the movie was
finished:
"Flying about 80 miles an hour.
Just a big chocolate missile."
When shooting another portion of the Wakanda
battle, Mackie had another important acting
moment, this time with co-director Joe Russo.
"Hey Russo, you want me to go Jamie Foxx on
this one?"
"No I want Denzel."
"Oh, s---.
Everybody put on your sunglasses, Denzel's
coming out."
And that wasn't the only time Mackie discussed
his acting process between takes.
During the film's intense final sequence,
Falcon rests slumped on the Wakandan forest
floor.
It's a heartbreaking moment for viewers.
Turns out it's because Mackie was channelling
his Infinity War co-star Don "War Machine"
Cheadle for inspiration:
"I'm going full Cheadle on this take.
Full Cheadle."
Black Panther vs. the Bleating Goats
Poised yet passionate, and undeniably powerful,
Chadwick Boseman's T'Challa, better known
as Black Panther, is generally able to keep
his cool under even the worst of situations.
This rings especially true in Infinity War,
when Black Panther gifts Sebastian Stan's
war-weathered Bucky Barnes a new bionic arm
and subtly asks him to join the resistance
against Thanos, whose Black Order was minutes
away from landing in Wakanda.
"This one may be tired of war, but the White
Wolf has rested long enough."
Upon seeing his upgrade, Bucky and Black Panther
have a simple, dramatic exchange:
"Where's the fight?"
"On its way."
The blooper reel features an extended version
of this moment which is...less dramatic.
The problem?
A couple of extras just couldn't keep quiet
during filming specifically, two chatty goats.
"I know you have found something.
A sense of peace."
[Loud goat noises]
"OK, now you are going too far!"
A hairy situation
Nearing the third act of the film, Black Widow,
Bruce Banner, Captain America, Scarlet Witch,
Falcon, War Machine, and Vision all travel
to Wakanda to visit Shuri, the genius younger
sister of T'Challa, who's known for her advanced
technological creations like the latest version
of the Black Panther suit.
The group hopes that Shuri can safely and
successfully remove the Mind Stone from Vision's
forehead and that they can destroy it before
Thanos seizes it and uses it to power the
Infinity Gauntlet, snap his fingers, and kill
half the universe.
Once in the lush, futuristic country, the
heroes wind up preparing to battle the purple-muscled
despot, with Black Widow joining the fight
inside a ship alongside Wakandan warriors
and members of the Dora Milaje .
Like so many scenes throughout the film, this
sequence was shot in front of a green screen,
but also required the use of a machine to
simulate real wind whipping past and the machine
kinda worked a little too well, both in this
scene and in one starring the Elizabeth Olsen
as the Scarlet Witch from earlier in the film.
"Because you're worth it!"
If they ever gets tired of acting, Johansson,
Olsen, and the rest of the Infinity War cast
could totally do shampoo commercials instead.